[Musique]
une ambiance cérémonial dans l'hémicycle
du département pour six collèges
volontaires qui travaillent sur les
questions de l' esclavage
cent soixante treize ans après son
abolition pendant la présentation du
musée de villèle ou encore des archives
départementales
les partenaires de ce projet annuel les
enfants sont concentrés sur les
nouvelles informations qui alimentent
leurs méthodes
après on a fait un arbre généalogique on
n'est pas ceux des sites
on n'allait pas souvent de familles sans
savoir d'où je viens
s'ils étaient nos arrières pas qu'ils
étaient nos arrière-grands-parents nos
ancêtres c'est très important vient
d'angleterre le portugal de madagascar
j'ai beaucoup d'origine de bien de pays
et tes parents il connaissait tout ça au
nom même j'étais très surpris on a
visité le musée de villèle depuis 2013
décoller et chez investissent dans cette
action départementale qui vise à faire
grandir nos jeunes avec leurs histoires
comme le département le fait
systématiquement à chaque grand rendez
vous autour de la question du sahara
d'associer les merveilles sur quelle est
leur perception aujourd'hui de cette loi
comment ils vivent au quotidien et
comment nous qui sommes tous héritiers
d'une histoire commune et bien nous
avons cette perception plurielle de la
question de l' esclavage et la notion de
crime contre l'humanité
objectif de cette étape comprendre
l'importance de la loi taubira qui
reconnaît la traite de l'esclavagé comme
crime contre l'humanité
pour cela un historien guidait leurs pas
ce jour dudit match je pense que quel
que soit le sujet à partir du moment où
on donne du sens
les élèves s'y impliquent et
ce que je trouve intéressant là dans le
projet du département c'est que ça
permet de donner du sens à ce que l'on
fait dans le cadre de la classe
la musique qui fait partie de l'histoire
résonne dans l'hémicycle prochaine étape
pour ces citoyens de demain le 20
décembre et la restitution de leurs
travaux
[Musique]